not gonna lie did not know what I was in
for with this one and okay this review
[Music]
wind river
so Wind River is written and directed by
Taylor Sheridan Taylor Sheridan wrote
hell or high water in Sicario he says
Wind River is based on true events I
don't know if that means this exact
story happened or if it means a story if
not many stories like this have happened
here's representation of it point is
it's unsettling it makes for a very good
phone it stars Jeremy Renner and
elizabeth Olsen yes I know that is me
saying there are two Avengers in this
movie not even gonna make a joke about
it Jeremy Renner is this tracker Indian
Reservation basically he's a hunter who
people will call and be like all right
there's these animals that are eating my
livestock can you please hunt them down
and shoot these animals because I need
to make a living here it's in the middle
of nowhere is very cold to believe he's
in Wyoming so yeah so we're talking
freezing here so while he's doing a job
he runs across the body of this dead
girl didn't FBI agents brought in that's
Elizabeth Olsen and it's really apparent
they're not gonna get a lot of outside
help here so Elizabeth Olsen really
wants to solve this murder and she tells
jeremy renner hey can you help me but in
reality jeremy renner so efficient it's
like yeah i'm pretty sure you're helping
him and he seems really invested in this
so we have ourselves a murder mystery
and a really good one i've done so
jeremy renner and elizabeth Olsen we
both know they're good at this point and
we know Jeremy Renner's really good he's
great in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
this is a different beast entirely
jeremy renner it's a really excellent
actor this comes as no surprise to a lot
of people I've seen I'm hard-pressed to
find a role he's been this good and dude
is completely efficient at everything
well when he flips his dramatic switch
he's on the movie really thrives on
illustrating the cultural barrier here
just in a matter-of-fact manner this is
clearly an undesirable place to live no
one would elect to live in this place oh
the place is very closed off very
isolated it's like we don't want your
health we don't need your help but the
gritty unapologetic nature of the
setting surrounding him people's what
makes his movie it's about when the
pathologist is doing the autopsy on the
dead girl and it's clear that it's a
murder but he can't actually legally put
homicide on the death certificate
because that's not how she died she died
because she froze to death and without
murder being on it the FBI can't get
involved and when I saw that I was like
I'm not so naive as to believe that
that's never happened you know that
happens and it just sucks it's just like
it's a shitty reality bomb that you get
at that point I'm not watching a movie
I'm watching an element of the world
I'm not regularly exposed to which makes
this a special yet bitter kind of thing
and I really went into this movie not
knowing what to expect people were just
like oh wind River you should watch it's
good a few people told me that only
alright whatever it is I guess I'll
watch it I'm glad I didn't know I'm glad
I didn't see a trailer I'm glad I didn't
get a synopsis I went into this movie
with naive hopeful eyes of wonder and I
walked out probably slightly different
than I was before I walked in there was
a scene in this movie it's just the most
effective kind of scene because the
phobic kind of scene I hate scenes like
this I hate to love them and love to
hate them it's an uncomfortable scene
where you know shit's gonna go wrong you
know shit's gonna go bad it does
sometimes I hate people guys in the end
this movie was excellent it was well
done glad I watched it it's not a movie
I got to watch multiple times or even
maybe again but the acting was great the
storytelling was superb the directing
was fantastic it's a great murder
mystery spearheaded by a man's man who
is on a manhunt but don't in a very
realistic way there's nothing
extraordinary or fantastic about it's
just people trying to do right by people
and I will say wind river is definitely
worth watching and definitely worth
buying on blu-ray yeah I said I probably
don't need to watch the movie again but
that's just my own sentimentality which
is no slide on the quality all right
guys so windriver have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's the
most emotionally impactful manhunt movie
or murder mystery for you whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]